hello everyone and welcome back to the
champions showdown we're continuing with
the
uh game already versus 11 iron and from
round four
uh of day two and it's uh quite a quite
a crazy game not a long one
uh just right for for a very enjoyable
sunday uh so without further ado let's
check it out uh as well it's it's a very
nice game
so it's not uh the exact same setup as
we've shown in the previous game uh
magnus carlsen versus wesley so the
bishop's pair
is fully operational already but the
knights are a bit
different than in that game uh which is
normal as this is round four
uh but uh the opening will be quite
similar so c4
sorry about that now of course both
players want to open up their
bishop pair we have c5 b6
so both players now open up their uh
bishop pair we can uh now make or make
these arrows
even though it's funny uh ever since
chess.com updated
their interface you can like make the
arrows go anywhere like you can make
this bishop
go here and you can make this bishop go
here so it's really weird
makes no sense but it is a lot of fun
like you you can do
like whatever you want this bishop can
go here here
here here like it's it's super fun
without actually making any sense but
not everything has to make sense if it's
fun uh so just wanted to mention that if
i ever make a wrong arrow then you guys
like like what are you doing with the
arrows
that's why why it's happening so e4
and now e5 uh just a nice symmetrical
follow-up we have knight to e2
and here knight to e7 11 just copies the
moves we have castles by ferruja
uh and here 11 breaks symmetry with
knight to g6
we have knight to c3 now uh gra going
for that the d5 square
he has a very nice control of the square
and as eleven played both
c5 and e5 he will not be able to kick
the knight away with any of the pawns
but
also alireza made a nice hole here on d4
and levin will of course use this for
his
outpost so knight to c7 uh preparing 96
and also
knight to d4 uh as joshua skin would say
exploiting the space left behind so
knight d5
and now knight to e6 of course preparing
to bring this knight to the d4 outpost
and g3 uh controlling this knight on g6
and also making preparations the strike
in the center with f4 we have knight to
d4 uh
just nicely placing that knight and
knight the g2 the knight will also help
out with
the uh pushing of the f pawn
uh here uh 11 castles now both players
have nicely castled and we have this
very nice position uh where both players
castle king side and both
players have a very fully operational
bishop pair so this is something that
quite often happens in chess 960 not so
often in normal chess
that you will have such nice bishops
pairs
every game queen to h5 uh a very nice
attacking idea by alireza uh just
bringing that queen into the game and uh
11 does have some plans of shifting this
rook over rook to c6 to h6
and the queen will be very useful there
as you'll see later on so rook the c6
now if the knight moves you can bring
the rook to help out with the defense
uh and the f4 uh striking in the center
as
as we mentioned e captures on f4 and now
eleven wants alireza to capture with the
knight so he can recapture with his
knight and then bring the rook here but
of course alireza doesn't do that he
just goes g captures on f4
uh messing up his king's pawn structure
a little bit but it's
uh it's all good if anything it can uh
it can even be useful you can maybe play
king h1 bring the rook over here you can
bring this rook to c3 maybe the h3 to
help out with the attack
a lot of attacking possibilities so here
at 97 making sure this
rook to h6 move comes very very soon
as you will need it uh and here alireza
decides to give up one of his bishops as
um
as long as this knight is here you don't
have any pawns to kick it away
uh it's gonna stay there for as long as
you allow it so here are bishop captures
on d4
we have c captures and now queen to h4
putting pressure on this knight
as there is now a double attack so you
don't have to worry about rook to h6
all that much and basically just
offering that queen trade if alone
if 11 wants he can just capture we can
have a queen trade and then you can
recapture here
and have a nice uh have a nice game uh
however
uh we have looked at e8 lemon says nope
uh queens stay on the board for the
moment
uh and alireza continues with e5 now
there is the threat of just queen
captures on h7
so of course you have to prevent this
with rook to h6
and now comes the move from the
thumbnail knight to f6
check and of course it's a very easy to
make a mistake here not by capturing of
course if you capture then you just lose
the rook but you could go
king to f8 and then you run into the
very unpleasant queen to g5 and now the
rook is lost you don't have a good move
uh you still cannot capture because of
queen captures and of course you cannot
go
rook to g6 because the bishop covers
that square so 11 goes for the only move
possible
king to h8 leaving uh some some squares
for this rook white still unable to
capture because the queen is hanging
so queen to g5 now by alireza and now
rook to f8
getting the rook out of harm's way uh
and now
knight the g4 attacking uh leven's rook
here
rook to h3 the only good square for the
rook
and now comes knight to f2 and now his
rook is once again under attack
but there is one move that allows 11 to
play for advantage
so feel free to pause the video here and
try to find this
advantageous idea while i give you a
couple of seconds
so uh for those of you who were able to
do it congratulations on spotting the
move
we almost never want to play and for
those of you who just want to enjoy the
show it's
f6 and f6 uh does a lot for this
position
uh for one it uh gets rid of the queen
from such a nice active square but also
uh it prepares uh the opening of the f
file
but also it prepares to bring this
bishop uh
well it it will bring this bishop come
alive uh as
once you open this then you really have
this bishop you have this bishop the
rook is already nicely placed here
uh and it's just gonna be a really
really open position and even capturing
doesn't do all that much for you once
you move the queen the rook is gonna
move now this rook is coming here and
it's just uh
it's game over for white so alireza
doesn't capture an f6 instead all it is
it goes queen g4 right away
but now rook back to h6 and now the the
same
rules apply you're still going to
capture here and not much not much is
going to change you do not want to
capture here and open up the g
file so knight the h1 by alireza and now
just
f captures an e5 with f captures and
now 11 grabs the pawn bishop captures an
e5
and now this uh at the position fully
opened up and you need to do something
about this so all it is are prepared for
this knight h1 to g3 now stops
any captures on h2 and knight the g8
here 11 prepares to bring the knight now
into the game alireza trades once
captures captures and
rook to f1 with knight to f6 blocking
and attacking
queen to g5 and now as the bishop is
under attack
d6 uh so uh
now alireza needs the needs to find the
move uh there
there are some ideas that uh you could
maybe uh create some threats here uh
towards this rook so alireza just
improves the position of of uh uh the
bishop bishop to d3
uh and now uh how do you push for
advantage here well uh
levan needs to do a few things first he
needs to well
do something about this pin you cannot
move the knight because just the rook
captures
queen checkmate so by taking this into
consideration and using the entire board
to find the move 11 finds bishop
captures and g2 and it is the strongest
move in the position
so king captures his force well not
force but i mean if you don't do it
you're just down a piece so i i guess it
is forced
king captures and now queen the c8
unpinning with the threat
well again with the arrow with the
threat of queen to h3
so nicely unpinned with h4 alireza stops
this
and now a5 prevents any advancements of
the pawns on the queen side from alireza
rook to f3 uh now adding more more
defense to the third rank but now
knight the g8 now the knight can be
removed also it's a very nice defensive
piece now the queen can move and you
don't have to worry about
any rook f8 ideas so rook to f7
uh rook to f7 uh just uh going for
some uh activity here putting pressure
on on this g7 pawn
uh if the if the bishop moves uh it's
going to be very
very tricky to defend so bishop to f6
now attacking alireza's queen and the
queen to d5 now
uh and here uh there is a very
interesting move that 11 didn't go for
11 win for rook captures on h4
and of course who could blame him you
just want to play queen to h3 and in the
game
but there was the very interesting 97
because it wins the exchange the queen
can no longer keep an eye on the rook
and after queen captures you're gonna go
queen here
attack the rook and now you will have to
give up the rook either by capturing
here or here
because if you defend uh by queen e6
then just bishop captures opens up an
attack and now again
you have to give up the exchange rook
captures rook captures captures captures
and you get the same game
where four points each uh but 11 would
be up the exchange in a completely
winning position
so after this queen to d5 move 97 very
possible but
uh rook captures on h4 is just much more
straightforward so this is what levon
plays with bishop to f5 preventing this
idea
and now queen to e8 again putting
pressure on the rook so the queen
doesn't really have all that many
options
so alareza offers a queen trade and now
uh it would be very dangerous even
though 11 is up two pawns it would be
extremely dangerous to play this because
now there's the threat of
rook here which just wins the game so uh
11 would have to block this and now
after knight f5 there's an attack here
there's an attack here there's an attack
here uh so you do not want to do this
11 plays the correct idea uh queen to b8
just gets the queen out of the way
uh defends the d6 pawn and now already
goes after it
rook to d7 but this is a bit too too
ambitious
bishop to e5 defense or also attacks
here defends the g7 pawn as well
and this is now a beautiful defending
piece and it's hard
for alireza to find any attacking ideas
so he goes for knight to e4 he wants
try something like knights the g5
followed by knight to f7 a nice mother
to checkmate
but queen to a8 immediately live on pins
the knight it doesn't allow such uh
such dirty ideas uh d3 i'll it is a
defense
once again as there was also the thread
of just rook captures giving up the rook
for two pieces so of course alireza
defense
and now g6 and this is a beautiful move
as it
uh frees up the f file for the queen and
there is one super tricky idea here for
alireza that i will show because it's
super interesting
uh rook captures on d6 removing the
defender of the bishop so threatening
queen captures and now
uh capturing the rook is forced queen
captures on d6
and now you would uh have to really
think about what to do because if you
capture the bishop
then white will win after queen captures
on d4 with
check you have to give up the knight now
you're going to play queen captures on
f6 with
check and now queen captures here and
now after f captures queen captures and
you get this position
uh where white is just up a piece uh up
a pawn and of course black cannot trade
queens as the king and opponent game
will be winning for white
so it would be possible however after
this queen captures and d6 move
black doesn't have to capture the bishop
you can just play queen b7
keep control of the g7 square and even
after you trade it's not a problem so
the the exchange sacrifice will not
really be
justified captures captures and the
black is just better here he's up the
exchange
so after this g6 move uh well it is
interesting
it loses terribly so bishop back to g4
but now uh 11's uh uh queen goes to the
f file and now well it
is just a really really big problem uh
we rook the c7 by alireza now preparing
rook to c8 to put a lot of pressure here
on unleavened
knight but uh here of course
black is completely winning uh it's
actually a fourth checkmate in three
which is a
one of the nicer checkmates i've seen i
don't think i've ever seen this
particular one
and levan also missed it so feel free to
pause the video and find it it's made in
three uh
while i give you a couple of seconds
so uh for those of you who are able to
do it congratulations on spotting this
elusive checkmate pattern and for those
of you who just want to enjoy the show
it's
rook the h2 check i'm sure all of you
saw this king ju1 and now rook the h1
check
uh and now there's not much you can do
uh if you go king to g2 then queen to f1
is checkmate but of course if you accept
the rook sacrifice
then queen to f1 is checkmate as the
bishop covers the h2 square it's not
nothing fancy but i just don't i
i don't think i've ever seen this
particular uh pattern like rook checks
then you sacrifice an h1
and then queen f1 checkmate but you know
just in case you have something similar
in your own games
uh you will be able to spot it uh but
okay after work the c711 went for the
second quickest idea which is queen to
f4
basically it's the same uh but uh just
prolongs the game a little bit this
bishop is a monster there there is no
attacking
moves here for alireza so you can just
try something bishop to h3
to kind of guard against the rook to h2
uh but
now comes queen page to check and it was
in this position on mu 40 that alireza
furuja resigned the game
and an excellent victory for levin who
not only won his game in game four uh he
started the the
the tournament with three draw three
draws on day one
and then he got three wins on day two uh
he defeated alireza in round four then
he defeated peter swiddler and then he
defeated
no i think first he defeated all it is
and then he defeated um
uh linear dominguez and then he defeated
peter swiddler
so three wins for him uh on on the
second day and here he resigned because
if king of three then just queen to f4
uh sorry rook to f4 will be checkmate uh
the queen now covers everything and the
pawn covers this
and if you go down the board king to f1
it's not much better
anything wins here you can even just
grab the piece and completely winning
even if
white goes to threat and checkmate here
uh you're still much faster just queen
f4
check you're going to go check you're
going to go check and here you're going
to just go queen to c1 checkmate
any pattern works so uh would be
pointless to continue
but yeah here are the standings just so
we don't forget
after day two uh you can see eleven
leading the tournament with four and a
half points like we said
three draws on the first date then three
wins uh and uh
uh for the last day eleven uh okay let's
just see it's carlson on the second with
four points followed by nakamura and
wesley so all of them with four
three and a half linear dominguez then
caruana with three kasparov
and peter swiddler with two and with one
and a half point
maxim bashar al-agrav uh and alireza
firuja
and for the last day we'll see if 11
will be able to go
all the way uh he has a really really
tough last day he faces magnus carlsen
gary kasparov and uh maxine varshilogrov
so we'll see
uh how it goes for 11. i'm very glad to
see that uh
11 has fully returned to the chess board
after all he is our
most colorful grandmaster so i'm very
well that things are
doing well for him uh over the chess
board and as i hear
uh in in personal life as well after
that terrible tragedy
so that's uh the game i do hope you
enjoyed it and that you're enjoying the
short coverage of the tournament so far
i would like to thank adam grippo
tobiasensel
patty and even for a contribution to my
channel thank you a lot i really
appreciate it as usual you can check to
my previous videos here thank you for
watching and i will see you soon
uh continuing the coverage of the
champions showdown
checking up on your wonderful
suggestions and whatever else happens in
the chess world
thank y'all i will see you soon and have
an excellent rest of your sunday